winter season has been a wrap and it's
been yet another fun and exciting season
there's a lot of things to like about
the roster of shows but i think one of
the things you've been looking forward
to is that postseason video where i go
over my favorite fights so here we are a
list featuring my favorite
confrontations and battles this winter
season and trust me there's quite a lot
of them let's start our season recap
with a bang
for something that started out being
mankind's fight for survival i think
that it's poetic that somewhere towards
the end of its run the biggest and most
brutal fights now involve humans going
up against each other it does truly give
a sense of perspective on morality and
human differences now doesn't it while i
enjoy the attack titan's last appearance
i think for this season i gotta give the
thumbs up to everyone versus the
jaegerists really this features some of
the best camera angles and motion shots
in this season of attack on titan attack
on titan has always excelled in this
department but for those who somehow
still doubt mappers metal in handling
the series this will erase all doubt
this is truly what they call sakuga oh
and who can ever forget this amazing
mikasa sequence she is truly the star of
the whole sequence easily one of if not
the best action-filled attack on titan
episode animated by mapa
a blast from the past yamato vs ace is
the next fight on my list
one piece is episode 1013 is one of my
favorite ones recently a large reason
for that is that we get to look at
yamato's flashback and get reintroduced
to ace turns out that ace and yamato ran
into each other before and the two free
spirits engage in battle it's just about
what you'd expect from a battle between
the two strong combatants gotta admire
ace's swaggy here though the guy
literally barges into freaking kaido's
home turf dispatches all the small fry
and straight up engages yamato all by
himself the resulting fight isn't one of
cataclysmic proportions or anything like
that but it is fierce and more
importantly a very important phase in
their respective backgrounds it paved
the way for the two of them to bond and
set in motion the yamato that we have
now so even before ace was setting the
road for his brother when you think
about it
[Music]
budgie versus boss is emblematic of what
ranking of kings is all about
this is david versus goliath taken to
the extreme bonji takes on boss in the
next series of seemingly impossible
battles that our plucky hero has to face
boss towers over budgie in every way
possible but as anime shown us no odds
are impossible to overcome the fight
really had those long moments that
allows the audience to marvel at wits
masterful framing and shots while
building hype for each attack and
response it's not an amazing fight in
the traditional sense that we've come to
expect thanks to being spoiled by ufo
table but it is a really great one from
a different perspective i'm not gonna
lie this fight did get me emotional but
that's to be expected already from
ranking of kings right
um
[Music]
there's one thing that i got to say
world trigger is quite underrated as a
shounen anime it's the series with a lot
of smarter and strategic battles and the
rank wars final round is a perfect
example of that it's a four-way battle
that allowed our characters to show off
their powers in creative ways with
teammates on your side new applications
of powers become possible and it feeds
more to the whole strategic thing i've
been praising world trigger for perhaps
most notably though however is the
showdown between yuba and nanomia two
skill combatants with one shot at glory
it's a short affair that people might
not see as a fight but it shows more
character than you'd think in a short
span of less than a minute you get to
see some deliberate moves and strategy
at play nanometer knew about the whole
20 meters thing and planned everything
to trap uber and use the latter's
tendencies against him ubar's a really
scary guy in close combat and ninomiya
respected the hell out of it with this
play
princess connect has been stepping up
big time this second season and the
final sequence continued pushing the bar
higher
[Music]
it's been a wild roller coaster of
emotions these last few episodes of
princess connect the chips have been
thrown and peccary now finds herself in
a battle for her rightful place as land
assaults princess there are actually two
fights happening concurrently here while
the underground fight has great
animation peccarine side of things just
blew me away in terms of how much
emotional investment i got her fights
really carried by the emotional weight
of all the events preceding it and
that's a fight that i don't think you
can take on its own unless you just want
to see breathtaking ufo table tear
animation of course pekerine also tossed
out one of the best princess strikes in
the entire anime here and take note that
she never did it without yuki but here
she did it not once but twice doubles is
one of the most satisfying moments in
both seasons to see kaiser just get
destroyed like that after all that's
happened mandatory fake out afterwards
but that's to be expected can't have a
final boss fight without the whole team
now right
i said two drawn out fights right
because the whole half of demon slayers
entertainment district dark is one very
long fight it's what i'll be closing
this list with
yes i'm putting the whole sequence
versus [ __ ] and guitaro here it's
actually a sequence of multiple
segmented fights that all join together
to form one long sequence and it's work
to perfection we get a switch of
combatants taking the spotlight which
allowed for a good spread of screen time
and for everyone to get their respective
highlights you get nezuko's grand debut
in battle you get tengen showing why
he's a pillar and who could forget
gutaro's dynamic entry into the freight
notice how i didn't talk about the
animation the presentation well i'm not
telling you anything you already know
demon slayer as an anime has set the bar
for awesome presentation causing a
series to break the glass ceiling and
into public geek culture and that's
something hard to dispute yes demon
slayer still does what demon slayer does
but is that a bad thing especially when
the fights are just so visually stunning
and just full of hype i really can't
wait for more demon slayer and all signs
are pointing to the team maintaining
this level of quality yeah we won't be
getting any one punch man situation
anytime soon and you have ufo table to
thank for that
so how well did your predictions age
tell me if you got your calls right or
not if you enjoyed this video don't
forget to hit the like button and share
the video with your friends you can also
help grow the community by joining the
channel's official discord come on hop
in and have some fun with your fellow
anime fans you know you want to you can
also follow us on instagram or give some
patreon donations if you're feeling up
for it those will greatly help grow the
channel so the team can keep producing
these videos for you all and don't
forget to check out our sponsors of this
video extra debit cards links in the
description thank you for watching i
hope to see you again stay strong and
stay awesome until next time